oh I'm I'm in shock and I'm so in love
with my brother right now he just held
me and said he loved me and I know he's
so happy for me and um
thank you for that and and um so thank
you to Colombia Winona you're amazing
and thank you for supporting all of us
through this and and all the girls in
this film are amazing and a whoopee
everybody and and my family for loving
me uh Janine schreier and your sister
Michelle Michelle we love you Guyer
Kaczynski my mom who's the most Brave
beautiful woman I've ever known and my
dad you're a great actor but you're a
better father
Hannah Jamie
you're just you I have nothing without
you you are the strongest most amazing
man I've ever known and I love you and
thank you so much